(musique militaire)
- Toujours deux pas derrière.
Il aura passé la majorité de sa
vie dans l'ombre de la reine
Elizabeth II.
Homme dur selon certains,
cocasse pour d'autres, le prince
Philippe était peut-être
l'un des personnages
les plus difficiles à cerner
de Buckingham Palace.
Né prince de Grèce et du
Danemark en 1921, il quitte
l'île de Corfou en catastrophe
alors qu'il n'a
qu'un an et demi.
La monarchie grecque vient
de tomber. Sa famille se réfugie
en France.
Sa mère souffre de
schizophrènie, son père part
vivre à Monaco, le jeune prince
se destine à une carrière
militaire.
Il devient aussi un athlète
accompli.
À 18 ans, il s'engage dans la
marine anglaise et rencontre
pour la première fois Elizabeth
venue visiter le collège naval.
La jeune princesse n'a alors
que 13 ans : c'est le coup
de foudre.
Le couple entretient une
correspondance, jusqu'à la
Seconde Guerre mondiale.
(explosion)
Philippe combat pendant six ans
sur les eaux d'Europe et d'Asie.
À son retour, en 1946, le jeune
prince est premier lieutenant
d'un destroyer et n'a pas oublié
Elizabeth.
Pendant des mois, ils se
fréquentent, mais le mariage
semble impossible.
Philippe n'a plus de trône et
l'entourage de la princesse
craint que le jeune homme au
franc parler ne respecte pas le
protocole.
Le public, séduit,
en décidera autrement.
En novembre 1947, leur rêve
se réalise. Un an plus tard,
Charles voit le jour. Mais leur
bonheur est de courte durée.
Le roi George VI meurt.
Elizabeth accède au trône,
à seulement 27 ans.
Pour Philippe, ce couronnement
signifie la fin de sa carrière
militaire et, contrairement
aux femmes de souverain,
il ne pourra jamais devenir roi.
Le prince devra se contenter
d'un rôle secondaire et surtout
d'être le plus discret possible.
Il portera le titre de prince
consort. Avec ses nombreuses
gaffes et faux pas,
le prince s'amuse des Anglais.
Mais certains diront qu'il avait
un charme indéniable.
D'ailleurs, les journaux à
potins vont rapporter plusieurs
frasques amoureuses
hors mariage.
♪ (trompette) ♪
Mais pour beaucoup, le prince
Philippe était un homme
de principe qui croyait en la
famille, qui a fini par avoir
le respect des Britanniques.
En mai 2017, à 95 ans il s'est
retiré de la vie publique.
Il était le soutien indéfectible
de la reine.
Ici Azeb Wolde-Giorghis,
Radio-Canada, Montréa